For this problem, you're going to develop a semi-implicit solver to model
just a single corner of the car and its motion.
You saw the diagram that look pretty much just like this in the unit.
Now all of these errors represent different types of quantities but they're just use for showing direction.
V here represents the velocity of the car. W is the tangential velocity of the wheel.
Mqc is the mass of one quarter of the car
and therefore, mqc*g is equal to the gravitational force on this quarter of the car.
F here represents friction or the force of friction that is
acting in this direction against the motion of the car.
The force of friction is a function of S, which stands for wheel slip.
We can write out the equation for the force of friction just like this.
The force of friction is equal to, as you've seen before,
the coefficient of kinetic friction, which is the function of wheel slip, times the normal force,
which in this case has a magnitude equal to that of the gravitational force.
We can relate some other important quantities to the force of friction, and right here
we can see that v-dot or the acceleration of the car is impacted definitely by the force of friction.
Change in the velocity of the wheel depends both on the force of friction and on B,
which is the braking acceleration.
S here, as you remember, stands for wheel slip as I just said.
We also have this expression from U, the coefficient of kinetic friction.
Your first task in this problem is going to find an equation
for W at the n+1 time step that fits this form right here.
In this equation, C, D, F, and K all could depend on a number of different things.
For example, it might depend on W sub n, on h the time step, or the mass at the corner of the car,
on the affective mass of the wheel, mew right here, mg the acceleration due to gravity,
on B the braking acceleration, or on v the velocity.
For v which you see right here, we're going to use v-sub-n because as it turns out
v changes very slowly compared to w.
In fact, what we have is a stiff system of differential equations.
You remember for our work earlier on in the course that stiff systems of differential equations
require you to use a very small step size or else we'll end up with completely unreasonable results.
If you want to test this out, try plugging in h=0.1 seconds for the step size
and see what kind of craziness this is.
In order to figure out what to plug in for C,D, F, and K here, we want you to use
the backward Euler method along with the information that we've given you here.
Looking at the code, you can see that we've given you a substantial portion of the program already.
In fact, we've handed you a solver right here.
Since we're asking you to use the backward Euler method, which is an implicit method,
you're going to end up with an equation that is not linear and therefore, you can't solve explicitly.
Once you've used the backward Euler method to come up with values for C, D, F, and K,
we want you to use this solver in conjunction with the backward Euler method
to come up with an expression for w[step+1].
In the solution video, I'll give you a more indepth explanation
of what do solvers do and then how it works.